police in germany have shut down a major
internet platform that shared images of
the sexual abuse of children
officials said the darknet site was one
of the biggest in the world and had been
operating since at least
2019. the investigation found
images of severe sexual abuse including
of toddlers
a civil custody several suspects are in
custody
the boys town website is now offline but
until recently more than 400 thousand
members
met up on this darknet platform to share
illegal images of young boys being
abused
after a lengthy investigation by germany
and europol
three main suspects were arrested
mid-april and a fourth is now in custody
authorities shut the platform down
all four men were arrested on suspicion
of criminal activity
they're being charged with conspiracy
and publishing pornographic content
three of them are accused of being the
administrators of the boys town website
the fourth is suspected of being the
most active platform member
and having made over 3500 posts
whether the men themselves committed
abuse is unclear
this can only be determined after the
data has been analyzed
even though the raid was successful
germany's federal police
know the investigation must continue
when you have such a large system and
cut off its head
you're only eliminating the current
administrators the members still exist
we have to assume that a similar site
will resurface
but that doesn't stop us from continuing
to prosecute those responsible for the
website
the offenders face prison sentences of
six months to 10 years
state prosecutors believe the suspects
will receive multiple years behind bars
well janina a seminova from dw's digital
desk has
researched the issue of child abuse
organized
through the darknet for dw's magazine
program shift
welcome to the studio um
how significant then is this latest
series of arrests
it's actually a major sensation for
german investigators i mean uh this
platform boys town we're talking about
um people
around the globe shared videos and
images of um
sexual abuse on this platform um
it is said to have had 400 000 members
so it is really a big if you put it in
perspective the last
big platform of this kind that was taken
down in germany
that had 100 000 accounts and now we're
talking about
400 000 members around the globe uh so
that actually makes it one of the
biggest uh dark web platforms of this
kind
right that we know of uh presumably um
and that brings me to my next point
because of course
these are illicit activities that
they're done in secret on this
dark web so they must be particularly
difficult
to um to investigate yes indeed they are
um i mean what you have to know about
the dark web is that it's a different
part of the internet so
that you can only access through
specific software which allows users to
remain anonymous
and of course this anonymity makes it
really hard to investigate these
platforms
which is why we've seen also this
international corporation
right now europol germany initiated this
task force other countries were involved
the u.s the netherlands and yeah what
investigators
basically do is they try to infiltrate
these platforms they try to talk to the
members in the chats
to just get any kind of information they
can to yeah have an idea where
any admin might be located to take them
down in the end
right 400 000 members at
four arrests here in in in in germany um
so that a lot of people i would imagine
uh out there just waiting for the knock
at the door
yeah we would hope that but uh still i
mean now
they arrested the admins but we don't
know
if they can actually get to other users
as i said this anonymity makes it just
uh so hard to actually locate the people
and
also the people that use these platforms
they uh they talk about encryption
methods
in chats uh that we see on these
platforms though so they are aware of
the fact that they might be taken down
and um yeah we also have to worry about
um actually
them taking to another platform which
often happens
so i mean it is a big sensation of
course this bus that this platform has
been taken down
but yeah we have to see in the future
that there hopefully won't be any other
platforms of this kind good talking to
you thank you for joining us
at yanina seminole
you